let me tell you something you're
familiar with daryl davis i'm not daryl
davis is the is the black blues musician
who de-radicalized over 200 klansmen oh
yeah yeah okay yeah yeah
amazing dude his story's incredible i
did an event where he was speaking
they threatened to burn the theater down
we do an after event
and he decides to go across the street
to the antifa protesters
and talk to them and they called him a
nazi and a white supremacist and refused
and he this
facebook posting i've never i've never
experienced this but
fossils encourage people to believe in
creationism so the point is
for them i talk about this in my book as
well for them
black is a spiritual state when that's
why bill clinton
is the first black president and
clarence thomas is not black
you laugh but it has an eternal life i
know i know
in the same way for catholics right the
eucharist the wafer
literally becomes christ's bones and the
wine
literally becomes his blood i think
that's the catholics who do that uh
literally you are no longer black and
literally
you are black if you are saved from the
sin
of racism and once you realize that's
how they look at things
everything else makes much more sense
it's i find it hilarious when
i like white people attack black people
calling racial slurs and these these
anti-protesters i don't think it's funny
at all
well i don't i don't mean funny haha i
mean funny as in unusual and
and like i i'm unnerving you know what
it is i've done so much work with like
north korea and
and the former soviet union and how
these totalitarian ideologies work
that when i see even the slightest bit
of it it
really make it really makes me recoil
and it's just like
this gets very bad very quickly and i
don't find
it cute at all like i get why you do i
just personally don't i'm not i'm not
but i am on the verge of laughing
because
you're wearing this hat yeah with the
the helicopter on it yeah
and you're talking about the soviet
union north koreans gulag
you know kind of stuff helicopters solve
that problem that's what i'm saying
are you at all concerned this undermines
or actually maybe it helps
no this is very good because it
alienates people who can only see things
visually and viscerally and those are
not the people i want on my side i want
people who are able to
hear ideas and think critically so this
is actually a good filtering device for
alienating people i wouldn't want to be
able to
be engaged with yeah that's a good point
perfect the the crazy thing about the
daryl davis circumstance was that
he could walk up to a klansman and
they'd be like
whoa and he'd be like how's it going
they'd be like hi and they'd talk
he couldn't do that with these far left
the klansmen is ignorant
right and had been taught a bunch of
ideas which is based on not it's very
hard
to be racist or homophobic or
anti-semitic or any of these other
things
if you know people from that group right
one of the best ways that gay rights got
over
was what i call like the ambassador
program because as more and more gay
people came out
and you were like blah blah they're
coming after kids you're like that's my
uncle
like he loves my nephew what do you then
that is personal
like this happened a lot you know with
the europe the jews it's like that's my
lawyer like or whatever it's like
he's maybe i don't there's you could say
certain bad things about him the fact
that he's evil
i'm not hearing this not even for a
second that is so
for the clan there's some people who
gives them status who are low status men
and and now they're okay they have a
cause
and you me just let me just really
quickly they meet the guys like this
guy's a cool dude this
is an a fundamentalist faith it is a
very different paradigm in my opinion i
was gonna say that's exactly what daryl
said
okay that when he would talk to these
klansmen and they would hang out
later when these guys were at the
meetings and they would say these things
about black people he'd go
that's not at all like daryl daryl's
doesn't act that way
as long as you have one your entire
narrative falls apart yeah
but these the but then in in terms of
the fundamentalist faith
i guess the shield is don't ever talk or
listen to anybody
of course because that's how that's
satan in the apple
because they're gonna tempt you into
faith into into sin
they're gonna they're sending temptation
to make you fall away
you need to stay with us and remain pure
whereas that is the impurity and that's
the slippery slope
one day you're listening to ben shapiro
the next day you know mine comp inside
and out as the new york times told us
but they're told this with a straight
face by the way hold up by a reputable
implication no one's gonna deny the new
york times a great reputation
at the new york's time is telling me on
a1 that if i'm reading ben shapiro on
monday
i'm going to be full uh getting swatches
tattoos on saturday are you saying the
new york times doesn't know what it's
talking about
you call mr propellerhead you you call
you refer to the media as the cathedral
is that the cathedral is broader than
the media the cathedral is the
universities the media entertainment
and the government and so this is but
this is like the leftist saw
fundamentalists
it's actually a progressive faith that
has its roots in the social gospel of
woodrow wilson and even a little earlier
yes and this has been the governing
uh as i talk in my book people think
america is a secular society
america is a more religious society than
ever just because a religion doesn't
have a
monotheist central god buddhism doesn't
have that right that does not make it
any less of a faith they have their
rituals
they have their televangelists who tell
them what to think uh rachel maddow
john oliver and very this is literally a
religion
they go on their facebook and spread
that day sermon to all their congregants
and you're coming into their church
and telling hold on a minute like this
is church sit down and shut up
we know what we're told because you're
gonna tell me that this man of the cloth
is wrong
or this lesbian of the croth is wrong
you don't know what you're talking about
and i'm offended
that you would dare come in here and try
to spit your sin
in my house of purity i think uh it's
peter begosian who refers to it as a
non-theistic religion yes it is
absolutely a fundamentalist evangelical
faith i was having a conversation with a
prominent
uh online lefty a few years ago and i
was explaining that i view these people
as
a cult and then i said you know we had a
discussion about it and there's like
these rules of cult hood
sure and and you know having having like
a figure yeah
so i was like so maybe it's more of a
religion yes this individual
you know disagreed with me a couple
years later they came back and said
everything they experienced with
religion was very very similar to what
they're experiencing now
and it's it's freaking them out yeah
absolutely and here's the other thing i
want people appreciate
this is something i have enormous
disdain for conservatives are
do not take people and give them your
children
to raise eight days five days a week
uh who are you they're training their
children
to hate you yep they socialists regard
your property as their property but even
more nefariously they regard your
children as their property you see
they're getting resentful
that there might be cameras in these
classrooms and it is a very sick and
this has been by design
they talk about making good citizens
making good citizens is a euphemism
for breaking young minds and making them
submissive and obedient and to have
their self-esteem
come from an external source namely that
mediocre man or woman at the
from the room who your approval is based
on whether they give you a grade
and it's based on whether they like you
or not more often than not it is a
horrible prussian evil system that's
been going on for 100 years
and that is something that really needs
to be the next front line
among people who are who care about
their kids now i'm just going to say one
more thing a lot of people don't have
the option
to go to private school of course that's
where the fight needs to happen
that money has to follow the kid there
need to be more choices for poor people
i was going to ask you at school choice
i mean i i'm a for school abolition i
say
i have i have said i agree i have said
many times
public schools are literal prisons for
children and the only place
many people will ever encounter violence
in their lifetimes
and we're told this is a really sick one
it's good
that you're bullied because it prepares
you for real life there is nowhere in
real life
where you are trapped for years with
someone
who is engaged in psychological warfare
or physical warfare against you
other than perhaps an extremely abusive
marriage and in that case
there are many venues to help you escape
it
and transition to a healthy life whereas
here
there's every opportun every chance to
close the door and make sure you do not
escape it is depraved and what if the
bully is your teacher
well the bull i mean no no i said this
also the teachers are the bullies the
teacher's job
is to break your spirit and make you
submissive and obedient here's some
things
that have some good teachers i'm sure
you have some here are some things that
are um
uh we just take for granted that you
think about your why is it that everyone
has to learn in the same way
why is it that everyone has to be on the
same timetable because there are prayers
of life in corporate america where
everyone just checks in at nine o'clock
which makes no sense you're
self-employed
why is it that everyone has to learn the
same things at the same rate
none of these things make sense in a
contemporary context but we still do
them
i agree abolish school yes
and the government monopoly in schools i
was homeschooled before
kindergarten okay i i just as long as i
can literally remember and fathom a
thought
my mom was homeschooling me and my
siblings that's wonderful when i started
school i was
just like just just far ahead
so it's really funny when i was in first
grade we there was a math game called
around the world oh yeah where
are you familiar with the game you you
stand up then you stand behind the next
desk
and the teacher gives you a flash card
whoever answers first gets to move to
the next desk
if you if you if you're standing and you
get it wrong you sit down in their seat
yeah
i'd never lose and neither would my
brother and so i got to a point where
they would ask us not to play
because no one was faster than us at
these at solving these simple you know
mathematical equations like
just basic edition multiplication
division i ended up
being uh just like the best part like
straight a's across the board
and then i remember when i left catholic
school went to public school all of a
sudden
it was very different now i think the
problem i had with catholic school
and i'm grateful for my experience was
that the catholic school was
so uptight everybody walked around with
sticks up their butts yeah
like kids would cry if they if they
stubbed their toe it was like
ridiculously weak
the public school was the exact opposite
it was chaos like
these kids were doing nasty stuff just
you know those gang activity and things
like that
and so i got to experience a little bit
of both but my parents
had actively been teaching me before
during and after
when i left the reason i went to high
school for about two months
i think or a few months i left um partly
because
i was lied to every step of the way yeah
uh in eighth grade they're like
look look i know you're upset and
unhappy here and you're being held back
because you're smarter and everybody and
all that stuff
grade wise it's not like you know i was
a genius at eight you know eight years
old but or i mean 12 years old
but then they said when you go to high
school there's going to be
everything's gonna be different you're
gonna learn the truth about all this
you know stuff you know about history
they're gonna get more in depth
and then i got there and it was the
exact same garbage yep and so i was like
i'm not going and i went from straight
a's to straight f's yeah
and that's when my parents freaked out
and they're like something's wrong here
yeah and then i went back to
homeschooling
and so you're very lucky we did this
correspondence program i never finished
i never got my diploma never got a ged
and
i i had this very easy realization when
i was young
the concept of uh wealth
wealth transfer and value is simple
the person sitting in front of me is
holding a green piece of paper how do i
convince them to let me hold that green
piece of paper
everything else was irrelevant in terms
of all these stupid arguments
it was simply a discussion of hello good
sir may i have that dollar yeah and
they might say yes and i was like wow
and now i have money i can do whatever i
want with it
and that's how you start a business and
that's the the fundamental aspect of
entrepreneurship
yeah but i look my my my family were
entrepreneurs
my dad ran side businesses he was a
firefighter my mom was tutoring
and things like that my grandpa had his
own business and so i was very lucky in
that regard
and having a a mom who you know she
tutored me
i watched my friends go to college they
get indoctrinated
it's horrifying they they they they
believe all these fanciful lies
you're going to go to college you're
going to get 50 000 in debt but you'll
be making a hundred thousand dollars a
year when you graduate
and then they go work at starbucks yes i
read i remember when i was uh uh
i think i was like 16 or 17. my dad did
want me to go to college
and i started reading this uh economist
who wrote an article saying
if you go to any investor and say for
forty thousand dollars
in four years you'll be forty thousand
dollars in debt plus interest they'll
laugh in your face
that's not even a real proposition yet
we do this to all of these college
students all day
so i learned something really
interesting uh later on in life when i
was probably around like 25 or 26 so
this is when i started covering
you know i was on the ground covering
occupy wall street i had a rising
profile i had
you know offers for work and stuff but i
was kind of doing my thing and i had a
friend who told me a story about
he tried hiring people for his job he
initially hired college students but
found they were incapable of doing
this kind of work because they struggled
and always needed direction could never
solve a problem on their own
he went through a few rounds of these
employees not understanding what was
wrong and then finally when he was broke
and he said i can't afford these kids
anymore
i'll just hire someone hourly problem
solved and the people he had hired for
hourly
moved to california to become actors and
what he said was i think these kids they
dropped out of high school
they made a decision for themselves i
need to go here to accomplish my goals
whereas these other college kids were
only people who had ever done what they
were told to do oh yeah
of course because now they've been
initiated into this it's a caste system
i think
i think it's been demonstrated i don't
have the study in front of me obviously
that by far the biggest divide in
america is in between race it's being
college graduates and non-college
graduates
um and historically it's been like okay
now this is kind of your entree
into a certain stratus of society uh
thankfully
people like you and many others are
demonstrating that this is his
uh you know relic of history it's it's
very hard
to teach people although it's
increasingly easy that it used to be the
american dream the gi bill right
no one ever my family ever went to
college my daughter's going to college
my son's going to college
this was a major accomplishment this is
objective proof
that our family is getting better that
our kids have it better than us
so it's very hard to knock that idea of
these people's heads and be like
you're paying a lot of money for your
beautiful teenage daughter
to go away and to come back as a swamp
walrus
with unnatural hair who loathes and
despises you
and will feel comfortable berating
grandma
at thanksgiving dinner because she
doesn't know how to pronounce the
pronoun
xir yes i think i figured it out
i have a theory okay gi bill
that's a there's a good point people
came back from world war ii yeah and
they were high school graduates no
degrees and they raised families yes
so then you have the kids of the
greatest generation
was it the boomers were the kids yeah
that was the boomers yeah the baby with
the world
after world war ii so the boomers they
are growing up in this world where they
were raised by a high school graduate
yeah
they're not they're not told to go to
college right because you can raise a
family with a high school degree yeah
a bunch of these kids become managers
and become mid-level you know mid-level
managers and
and they run stores and businesses and
they're making okay money yeah but then
they look at their siblings
they're making six figures and this is
back in the you know the 80s
how are they making so much money they
went to college right i should have gone
to college yes
then they tell their kids you have to go
to college yes because your uncle did
and look how much money he made
and but they're missing something and he
was just one more thing and he get he
looks down on us and i get why he does
they're missing something if you were
never told you had to go to college
and you chose to go to college you made
a decision for yourself
and you were pursuing your passion sure
it wasn't college that made them wealthy
it was their own passion and drive and
college was just them saying what's the
next step in becoming
an architect or whatever now they've
told all these kids
to succeed you must go to college and
those kids don't care and don't know
and they take out massive loans yeah and
they go to school and say oh
and then the guys the the the the school
says well we recommend i guess
i don't know you want to be a journalist
oh well put them in journalism there you
go congratulations if the public
education system worked as planned
you wouldn't need to go to college
because that high school diploma
would be proof not just evidence proof
to most companies
that this guy can do a girl can do a
great job on day one
that they are skilled and this is a
certificate that has meaning
the fact that a high school graduate is
absolutely meaningless in our day and
age including
possibly being illiterate is now like
okay well now this is the degree that
counts
what they ignore even if they had the
best of interest which i do not think
for a second
is that this is another four years where
this person
is not an economic benefit to the
culture he's not he or she's not working
they're students they're net loss to the
economy so that's what from instead of
going from one
to seventeen where they're not producers
now it's one to twenty one
four years in terms of adults working
lifespan is a significant
chunk of that change for them not to be
in the job market and this is an
economic cost that they just pretend
doesn't matter
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you